books books i love books the way they  feel and smell and look from my first  book i was hooked on books books books  country icon dolly parton was in ohio to  celebrate the success of her  long-running book program that she  developed for kids all the while keeping  it really candid on the importance of  educating youth to learn to love reading  even if you can't afford  to go to college or to go to school like  my dad if you can read  you can self-educate yourself and so  that's kind of what we're hoping to just  teach kids to read and to learn to love  books dolly ended the night with a  musical performance surprising guests  with the announcement of her upcoming  nbc dollywood christmas special  we're kind of dramatizing it like what  goes on behind the scenes of making a  movie and just what you know the  problems that you do have and i think  people enjoy that kind of stuff so  anyway it's called  mountain magic christmas dolly dollars  magic mountain christmas